nos preguntan cuánto tiempo ha pasado
desde la hora de la izquierda que es
esta hasta la hora de la derecha que
vemos justo aquí y dicen que el tiempo
transcurrido es menor a 12 horas
como siempre pausa el vídeo y trata de
responder esto por tu cuenta antes de
trabajar juntos muy bien lo primero que
quiero saber es que ahora dice cada uno
de estos relojes así que vamos a la
izquierda lo primero que haré es mirar
la manecilla de la hora y podemos ver
que la manecilla de la hora ha pasado un
poco más de las seis entonces son seis y
algo seis y algo y luego quiero saber
cuáles son los minutos puedo ver el
minutero justo aquí bueno qué tan lejos
ha llegado en minutos y me gusta contar
de cincuenta y cinco porque sabemos que
de las doce del reloj a la una en
realidad han pasado 123 45 minutos de
hecho entre cada dos números hay cinco
minutos
entonces son cinco
15 20 25 30 35 40 y luego 41 42 43 ahí
es donde está apuntando son las 643 es
donde comenzamos y luego veamos donde
terminamos la manecilla de la hora está
un poco después de las 9 puedes ver que
son más de las 9 la hora no es
necesariamente la que está más cerca es
la hora por donde ya ha pasado incluso
si la manecilla de la hora estuviera
aquí más cerca de 10 pero no del todo a
las 10 diremos está bien son las 9 y
algo son más de las 9 y si llego a las
10 o después de las 10 entonces iremos
son las 10 y algo entonces son las 9 y
algo y para descubrir qué es ese algo
una vez más comenzamos aquí podemos
contar de 55 5 minutos 10 minutos y
luego tenemos uno más llegamos a 11
minutos entonces son las 9 11
nos dicen que el tiempo transcurrido es
menor a 12 horas de diferencia entonces
no son las 643 en un día tal vez en la
noche y luego las 911 de la mañana
siguiente tal vez sea la misma mañana o
la misma tarde de modo que aquí podemos
configurar una línea de tiempo veamos la
sexta hora va a ser importante las seis
en punto y déjenme ver tal vez queremos
llegar hasta las diez en punto para que
vayamos más allá de las 911 y entonces
vamos a poner siete ocho y nueve sólo
quiero tener mi espacio correcto digamos
que son las siete en punto justo aquí
aquí son las ocho en punto y justo aquí
son las nueve en punto no es un dibujo
perfecto pero está bastante cerca y así
que vamos a ver estamos comenzando a las
643 que va a estar más o menos aquí
aquí es donde comenzamos y luego 9/11 va
a estar más o menos aquí que es donde
terminamos así que cuánto tiempo ha
pasado para pasar de las 643 a las siete
en punto cuántos minutos son
para pasar de 43 minutos a 60 minutos
tienes que agregar 17 minutos entonces
esto de aquí son 17 minutos
lo voy a escribir y luego podemos ver
que tenemos otras 2 horas de las 7 en
punto a las 9 en punto son 2 horas y
luego para pasar de las 9 en punto a las
9 11 cuánto ha pasado bueno son otros 11
minutos 11 minutos así que cuánto tiempo
ha pasado son 17 minutos más dos horas
más 11 minutos bueno me resulta un poco
más fácil pensar en los minutos primero
entonces y sumó 17 minutos a 11 minutos
17 + 11 es 28 puedo hacer la suma de
este lado si quieres ver la 71 son 81
más 1 son 2 entonces tendremos un total
de 2 horas y 28 minutos y podría
escribirlo de esta manera 2 horas y 28
minutos y hemos terminado